[Musique]
bon
bien
[Musique]
oh
ça me rend fou gens normaux je suis
devant c'est l'enjeu le monde
seulement
seul pourtant
me ans au nez encaissé façon
16 ans dernier sou mais tant que je
ressens c'est une monde prend tous
notamment des portails comme si
longtemps
c'est par le torrent parler les indices
tels bank paris
je peux lui en ce moment
bien peu d
dans le
y a plus d'essence dans
plus d'oxygène dans la poitrine
[Musique]
je sens tu là
en pro a puis
en sueur
le sens tu
moody's
[Musique]
la droite début de sang
on
oh
me détruit un peu plus chaque jour
moi c'est même un jeton pam à jour
mon âme ces palabres entre 1
j'ai peur des problèmes dans notre un
poumon et procure tout le monde et qu'on
met toi tu grimpes au long cours de
suippes appel à
oh
tu veux fuir ce moment
en heure y a plus d'essence dans leur
nom
il ya plus d'aisance dans l'eau
auteur plus d'oxygène dans la poitrine
du jeu sans dents
des senseurs
[Musique]
si je donne pour acquis
je suis j'aime dans la boîte
jobs
deux sens
quand il a bu
c'est un peu senti un peu sentiments
sans tuer la peur